so today I listened to my dating coach  she said you do not get your expectation  you get your minimum standard  is your dating coach married yes and she  has a baby and her wedding ring is at  least five carats yeah and her man is  rich excuse me you know what he herself  makes like 30 to 50 Grand a month  coaching women in love  I mean good luck if that like works for  you I just like to me that sounds like  a 200k engagement ring like I think like  guys are gonna hear that and be like no  no no you don't have to have the man  who's okay with maintaining you  right with maintaining you right like  you can be high maintenance but if you  are dating a man that is okay with  maintaining you you're fine you're not  high maintenance then you're just on  their level